latest update this is link or if you
don't know where this is then this is a
shortened version you see a link
okay good morning okay good morning
everyone just before we start there are
some files that we'll be using today I
posted this on the discussion board and
they'll be around the group page and
also on PI's so please download the
files and unzip them so that you have
all the internal files in the folders
I'll be referencing them again you can
either copy this link or you can go to
the organization page and download these
files would be very helpful if you
already have your account pulled up all
in platform so that you can follow along
on the practical steps
okay so today's session is going to be
the introduction to our new seat this is
a workshop one of the first workshops
that we do we will try to follow a
similar process in later workshops
basically this is going to prepare you
for the online materials if you've
already started thinking all my
materials that it's good because you now
understand what is happening but I think
this will be a little bit more engaging
and I think as you prepare for the
future workshops just have it in mind
that every session will have some files
will actually work through some examples
we'll look at them out of course so
please have your computers have your you
know counts ready all of that
information before the person in Plato's
adjust came in all of the files for
today's session including this
presentation is going to be on this link
when you need to do is go to this link
download the zip file unzip it and then
have all of these files ready on your
computer so you know where they are
competing if you have any other
questions you can access your account or
anything like that
seal is here in the back he can help you
and also for any of you that have any
technical challenges and at the website
josh is here in the back and he would be
the person who talked so as you remember
in the previous session when we did an
introduction to this course we talked
about different types of onyx data and
we specifically talked about how
processing this data analysis of this
data is going to be the focus of the
sessions and as you can imagine
different methods for processing the
data were created at different labs or
different universities with different
coding languages so it's an assembly of
different methods and to appreciate how
these methods fit together and how do we
utilize them to address biological
question
we've assembled them on the platform and
today what we will do is we will try to
test some of these methods on the
platform and prepare for these
explanations the projects and the
step-by-step tutorials on the
educational site so the first section
over there on the tab is called
transcriptomics RNA seek that's going to
be one of the sections for processing
the data then we will take a look at how
to just prepare the data from short
reads to a table of expression and how
to do differential gene expression the
second thing that we'll look at is a
little bit of exploratory analysis if we
have enough time and that includes so we
will talk about some machine learning
methods in the context of RNA seek how
do we do things like pca explore our
data visualize the data and then we will
talk about utilities and in the
utilities we have a couple of methods
for interpretation the quality of this
is good enough but we'll see how do we
convert the gene IDs that we get in the
gene expression table to something
meaningful something that we can look at
from a biological perspective now this
is an introduction to this series of
lessons that could be taken online and
what do they cover so just a brief
overview we already completed
introduction to bioinformatics and the
main point that I hope you can take away
from that is how big data is changing
our understanding of biology and then
because of this availability of data how
do we utilize data mining so hypothesis
free exploration of that data to
understand specific biological processes
and answer some of our questions about
that biology transcriptomics one two and
three is going to walk you through
processing the data from raw reads to a
table of expression hypothesis testing
methods like differ
gene expression or t-test students
t-test and then we'll use methods like
regression and classification and other
machine learning methods to explore the
data and the main challenges challenges
are separation of signal versus noise
and understanding how do we leverage our
existing knowledge about some data set
for a new data sets how do we use data
patterns to find Association and
correlation between these patterns in
data after we complete these three
sessions we'll talk a little bit about
single-cell transcript Thomas
single-cell transcriptomics is going to
leverage all of these concepts that are
explained in these three sections
because really it's an application of
the same processing and alignment
methods as well as some of the machine
learning methods to understand this
another level of complexity that comes
with single-cell ardency so in summary
for the whole session we will be talking
about RNA seek as a step-by-step process
of preparing the data which is
processing right how do we structure
eyes the data that comes from the
sequencer then how do how do we apply
different statistical methods to
understand what's in the data and do
hypothesis testing and then how do we
interpret the results so once we have
them how do we do interpretation and
this is done in several steps so each
one could be divided broadly this is
very broad kind of overview of what we
will be doing pre-processing so how do
we eliminate technical variation that we
don't want to include in our analysis
and how do we map the reads the raw
reads that we have on what are we
mapping on the whole genome are we
mapping all the known transcripts to
different mapping strategies and then
quantification
what are these numbers that were looking
at and how do we normalize those numbers
so that Li can compare apples to apples
and not be confused by the variation if
for example in gene length or the total
number of reads that we have that might
be different between different samples
for the statistical analysis a lot of
people tend to jump to hypothesis
testing and probably in a premature way
right so that's éxito pipeline that goes
all the way from mapping to differential
gene expression blacks certain
understanding and appreciation of data
is variation and how can we normalize
that data before we jump to that step so
we'll talk a little bit about
exploratory data analysis how do we
explore those patterns in our bond data
we will talk about hypothesis testing in
this in multiple ways so hypothesis
testing could be done with methods like
students t-test and what are some
considerations about false discovery
rate adjusted the p-values and things
like that but also classification is in
some ways a way to extrapolate our
knowledge or understanding about the
underlying biology and explore that in
the sense of data and primer primarily
we'll be interested in feature selection
that means when we see a difference how
do we understand how genes or their
expression that will really shows us a
quantification of that difference and
then we will talk a little bit about
data mining
so again data mining from several
perspectives one of them is how do we
just explore the patterns in the data
and how do we interpret those patterns
but also how do we understand
associations between different types of
data sets and between different patterns
that we identify in the same dataset or
between different agencies for
interpretation one way to interpret our
data is of course visualization we can
just visualize them and kind of
summarize what
in the data visually we'll talk about
annotation so how can we use reference
databases to imitate what we see for
example with gene ontology z' and things
like that and and we'll also talk about
novel discovery so sometimes we're not
just talking about what did I find from
known things but how do I actually find
something completely new and primarily
that will be relevant for non-model
organisms or or very severe
modifications of what is known the first
part is processing of that data and this
is really covered in detail in
transcriptomics one processing of data
could be summarized in these several
steps so we do pre-processing and that
just relates to how the data is prepared
what is the raw data in terms of the
biological sample before it gets into
the sequencer so we want to address some
of those technical preparations that's
alignment and how which files are we
using for alignment what is the
reference genome what is the GPL file so
an understanding of all of those things
quantification how do we measure what it
what are some methods of measuring the
gene expression levels and then
differential children's question now
Before we jump into that in the online
modules we will be primarily using a
data set from publication on
patient-derived xenograft models PDX
models but in this session I will use a
different data set and so the idea is
that the methods and your selection of
methods or strategies for analysis is
going to be tightly linked with what
dataset you're using and you'll see how
selection of the genome of the reference
genome or even different mapping and
analysis strategies will change between
different
so as you go through these workshops in
person or you know in these sessions and
when you do the online materials you
will see a lot of similarity but
difference is because of the design so
Before we jump into the processing and
the analysis it's important to
understand what are we trying to study
because that will help us understand the
significance of what we're finding so
what we'll deal with today is a dataset
from a study related to precision
medicine in the context of breast cancer
so what you see here is a mammogram and
this spot right here that is highlighted
with red arrow is a tumor or some
suspicious collection of cells and the
first objective from a clinical
perspective is of course to characterize
what exactly is this tumor where is it
coming from for example which tumor is
it originating from so to understand
that we can kind of dissect and
understand the different tissues and try
to pinpoint visually or in other ways
the source of that tissue so one way
that we can do that is by looking at
receptors so using antibody staining or
immunohistochemistry to check for
presence or absence of specific protein
right all of this is going to be
relevant in the end to the actual
dataset so just to give everybody a
conceptual overview now the limitation
of that is that you can only look at
several types of proteins at the same
time and you are kind of getting there
to the presence or absence based on
availability of antibodies so that is a
major limitation but that could be
overcome by looking at gene expression
right so we know that mRNA is going to
be produced into protein so these are
linked things and so we can look at
something like this which is a gene
panel and it shows us a little bit more
information right so it shows us for
example more genes and it shows us also
high expression levels medium expression
levels or normal expression levels and
expression level and that's where we get
the terms from of over expression under
expression and standard expression or no
change what you see here is a PM 50
panel so it contains 50 genes over here
on the side so your rows are going to be
genes and your columns so to say are
going to be subtypes of cancer so
subtypes of breast cancer so and so
you'll see typically in your gene
expression table is something that looks
very similar to this your columns are
going to be samples and your rows are
going to be Jesus how is this
information useful what is the purpose
of getting this kind of information
about the sample well the first useful
information that we have is our ability
to prognosis it category of risk does a
patient fall and so for example what you
see here are kaplan-meier curves for BAM
50 and Oncotype DX these are two
commercially available panels are used
in clinics to understand survival rate
and the rate of returns for different
groups of patients so you might want to
understand whether a patient's has a
high risk of recurrence or of of death
or low risk and based on that
understanding you can now select
different treatment strategies if it's
an aggressive tumor that is growing fast
and it's metastasizing your primary goal
is to suppress that growth growth and to
stop it from spreading as opposed to a
more mild tumor that you might want to
be more aware of the side effects of
these very harsh treatments now not so
long ago probably in the 1990s there was
an emergent emergence of precision or
targeted cancer therapy and one good
example of that is Herceptin so
Herceptin
works in the following way it is a an
antibody that essentially blocks a
receptor and prevents a specific growth
factor from entering the cell with that
receptor present and therefore you can
stop this proliferation of cells now
this gives us a good understanding so
it's actually linked to our
understanding of presence or absence of
a specific receptor of a protein but
also our detailed understanding of the
process so that growth factor enters the
cell and causes different pathways to be
activated therefore causing
proliferation a biological process that
we want to intervene it so this type of
understanding really led to a whole
range of precision treatment options and
those are actually linked to how we
profile patients and so profiling with
patience and understanding of molecular
factors that could help us differentiate
between patients actually is the key
factor in precision medicine so
therefore the data set that we're using
is somewhat of a representation of this
whole problem
it's a publication from 2013 that is
called and you have this publication in
your zip file that you just downloaded
called modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer what they did is they had
a collection of different cell lines
derived from patients that were grown
and then two things were done first of
all they were profiled based on their
RNA seek exomes seek chip seek to all
the different types of omics and the
same time the same cell lines were
treated with different types of
treatments both available clinically and
experimental and inhibition of growth
was measured so they measured the time
from when this drug was stopping
proliferation of those
and so it gives a good insight into
effectiveness of a treatment for a
specific molecular profile so in several
of our sessions we will be using this
data set so some of these files are
available in that zip and what I want to
just make sure that everybody has the
files unzipped and you can see some of
these folders so you're not going to see
all of them because we're not going to
cover everything in today's session but
what you should see is expression
quantification under input files so
please make sure that you see that and
specifically the site the file that
we're looking for is samples SPL right
here so if you have this sample could
you just raise your hand you have that
file samples on this feel all right so I
think that's 95 percent that's pretty
good
so what is inside this file inside this
file all we did was we downloaded the
wrong fast Q files and we uploaded them
on the server then we're going to be
working on and so you have sra so
sequence read archive files that are
represented by paired fast Q file so you
see the underscore one and underscore
2's array is an archive kind of like a
zip archive so you have to extract the
sra archive and then you get what's
inside which is raw fast q files
now these master files come from cell
lines so just so that you have a sense
of exactly what the labels would be as
you can see each cell line has a name
and that name could be associated with a
subtype so what are these subtypes you
have subtypes that have better prognosis
worse prognosis and kind of different
ways of categorizing these cells
specifically for today's session we will
be looking at only a subset of those
cell
so we will take all of the normal life
or non malignant cells and cloud and low
so in total we will have eleven samples
and you can see visually these are just
two examples they are very different
okay so just to explain what are these
file types the first file type that
we'll be dealing with our last few files
and I hope that you can see on the
screen here a little bit what it has
inside is a sequence of nucleotides with
some additional information so it has
information of quality of that lead
coming from the instrument in this case
it was sequenced using an Illumina
sequencer and so some of that quality
information is included in every line
for each read of that sequencer we will
also refer to fast a files and so FASTA
files are going to be in the reference
genome that we're mapping to fast the
file is the exact same thing but it
doesn't have any quality files it's just
a complete sequence of the full genome
the third file that we'll be referring
to is the GPA file sometimes people use
the GFS file but the GTF file contains
information about what's inside the GTF
what is what is the beginning and the
end of the gene what is the exon exon
name gene name etc so how do we know
what you have - it's in the GPR file and
of the FASTA file what are we mapping so
as you all remember DNA is transcribed
into RNA internet RNA is then
transformed into mRNA and then mrna is
finally translated into protein so what
we're focused on is mRNAs and mRNAs
actually are somewhat you know they and
they get to their final form and a
fairly complicated process a lot of it
related to alternative splicing so how
do the different exons are spliced
together and how do they form what
we end up seeing as transcripts so let's
take a look at this process in detail
and try to understand what exactly are
we expecting to get in these raw fast
cue files so the main question that we
are interested in is what are we exactly
measuring when we end up getting this
table of expression so what we're really
trying to look at our genes and isoforms
or what is the real thing that we're
measuring as opposed to what we use as a
reference so this is a sequence of a
gene and this is recorded in the GTF
file as you remember right so the GTF
file will have the position the
beginning of the gene the end of the
gene and all of the exons in between and
the position of the exons and introns
and then we will have this fast cue file
which is where the raw reads from our
sequencer and then we have to align the
reads to this sequence that we have in
the GTF file and we have a number of
options so for example one isoform
as you can see is a connection between
three different exons and then we have
either form 2 both of them come from the
same gene and then we have different
numbers of reading you can see that we
could be at different lengths and they
could align differently to that exome
and then we have two different
conditions for example and now we want
to try to understand how does one
condition different from another
condition by comparing the number of
reads aligned to this gene right so that
is the objective and just to give you a
reference what does the GTF file
actually you look like so this is an
example of what it looks like you can
see the beginning chromosome 15 for
example you have a heads on it starts
from a certain position on that
chromosome it ends in a certain position
on that chromosome and then you can see
that it has a name and so what is that
taxonomy of things you
with general name for the jeep and then
you have a variation so however many
numbers you of exons you have in that
gene and that's what you get in the
final table so this is to clarify the
data that we will be referring to now
how does splicing affect our mapping and
why is it important to remember that
what we are interested in are junctions
between exons because they're really the
hard evidence that we have eggs on
splice together so in the beginning we
will have reads that map to some region
so you know that they fall within the
boundaries of a specific X R and then
you will have some unmapped reads reads
that didn't fall really it with a good
quality on this exon or another exa
however within the sequence you have an
evidence that this read contains some
portion of this exon some portion of
that exact and this is hard evidence
that they're spliced together so that's
how we start to assemble the isoforms
and when we look at the pipeline we will
see how the steps that we take on the
pipeline actually represent this kind of
process where we map some reads and we
identify exons then you look at
junctions between exons make isoforms
and then we plot apply now there are
some exceptions to remember here and
this relates to the strategies that we
rely on when we do our study so if you
are looking at known genes and known
transcripts you're really interested in
just reads that fall into one of those
known regions but that's not always
going to be the case so real biology is
much more complex than how we document
it and so here are some good examples of
introns for example being expressed
under a certain
or only portions of exiles being present
and portions not being present so what
that really means is that we have a
limited understanding for exactly what
those regions are and how they work
together especially in disease
conditions and in novel organisms and so
if we're interested in those types of
changes we should probably avoid mapping
on transcripts and focus on mapping on
the full genome and then looking at what
types of variations do we see what kinds
of gene fusion do we see what kinds of
differences in alternative splicing and
how do we evaluate even expression of
introns and not just exons and and then
the interpretation of course becomes
much more complex because all of our
database driven interpretation is going
to be focused back on transcripts and
known events that have been done so now
let's talk about the role of
pre-processing and what are we exactly a
pre-processing before I do that does
anybody have any questions about putting
sense of farmers everything you could
find that reads making what are the
reads so the sequencer though the
sequencer produces short reads it can
only read a certain length of army so
RNA is translated into cDNA and then
eventually you read that sequence and
you might have anywhere between 20
nucleotides to maybe 200 or 300 long
nucleotide now a gene could be several
thousand nucleotides long so if you have
several thousands of nucleotides and
then you have a 200 long read you want
to map that lead in some region of that
it matches with some quality so you give
a threshold of quality and then you
eventually map it in different regions
and the reads
stack up in a certain region and that's
what we call you know an expression of
that region it could be an exon or some
kind of a region that we give no the
beginning at the end and the height so
that would be the level of expression so
these reads represent what we have in
our sample and what we mapped to is the
reference genome so that would be the
FASTA file of the human genome for
existin okay so let's take a look at
this process of technically kind of what
happens so again we have some portion of
the genome that portion of the genome
encodes several genes for example gene a
gene B and gene C and then in our actual
biological sample only gene a and gene B
are expressed so they produce a
transcript and now what we're interested
to do is we're interested to look at the
shattered trees right so these portions
have been found in these short leads but
in reality this is a little bit more
complex right so in the preparation what
happens is we have shadowing first then
we have adapters that are attached to
the beginning and the end of that
sequence and then afterwards we do PCR
amplification right so we need more
material than is typically found and so
we amplify the amount of reads that we
have and as a result we then read
something that somewhat represents the
original sample but not exactly and so
because of that the whole process of
analyzing this data reflects this
biological way of preparation preparing
method so the first step is
pre-processing removing those adapters
and trimming known sequences that come
as a result of the library preparation
then we map or we align those reads to
the reference genome and we have several
strategies that we all
they talked about and then we quantify
so we need to put a number to it and so
we'll talk a little bit about what are
the different strategies that we have
for quantification so because you just
joined I just don't want you to be
behind but there there's a file or a
number of files that we are working from
so you put download so this is posted
also in the organization page but this
is a short link well you'll find there
is a zip archive for files that we'll
use as input during the session I
recommend you just download the entire
zip file try to view them in the Dropbox
because some of the files are not
viewable and I just tell them to file so
just grab that entire zip to your
computer that way alright so we were
talking now about pre-processing and so
actually as we already know what we need
to do let's go ahead and do that on the
platform so if you can all go to server
the T - bio info or you should see is
the areas of analysis and we will be
looking at this top section ok so if you
click through the first part that will
come up is this selection on top and
this is the selection that we want to
make so we want to first of all we are
using a model reference genome which is
going to be the human genome the latest
assembly grch38 and we will import fast
queue files that are pair ends and their
end means that the read is being read
from both sides and so we have them
having two files for each sample and
then we will merge them and as you
select that on top and I will do this
all with you just in
second here what you will want to do is
select URL bulk upload right there and
that is where you upload that SVL files
okay so let's go ahead and do that
together so if I go to areas of analysis
I will then see this top section I will
change it here to grch38 I will change
this one to parent and then we can
upload here using URL bulk upload and
what you saw is sample status field so
after it uploads all the weight will
press I defined groups check and this is
what's inside the svl so you can see
that these SRA archives are paired
together and you have underscore one and
two each one the groups are going to be
useful for differential gene expression
all right so if I want to compare a
number of samples versus a number of
other samples in two groups I can drag
them I can create two loops and drag
them appropriately oh so what I've said
all times
yeah yes okay let me do it from the
beginning so I do parent here I choose
your speech 38 upload files and groups
and I don't do have file right so this
would be if you actually have the past
few files but we only have references so
references go right here URL both upload
you click on that and you select samples
that svl you choose after it's uploaded
define groups check
and now we have the files listed after
you have the files listed you could
create a couple of groups and drag them
into groups but we're not going to do
that right now we're not doing
differential gene expression we're just
generating a table of expression at this
moment the start page where you up from
the main menu I am under army seek so if
I go to areas of analysis it's this
first one so I go here upload files and
ad groups URL both upload sample Dallas
VL fine oops check I can just do cancel
and then you can see that this has been
completed and I can start creating my
pipeline and obviously the first thing
is the only thing that's available is
starch and you can read a little bit of
this overview and if you want to read
this okay so after the files have been
uploaded you just press on start right
and so the pop-up shows you kind of
what's what's the process and we can
read this publication to read more about
RNA see
now after we say okay we see some
options available to us so you can
probably remember the colors that we
used right we have blue for
pre-processing which is right here
pre-processing and you can click on that
and you can understand what that section
does and then if you remember we had red
so mapping on genome and all of the
things that we talked about eggs on
detection mapping on Junction eyes
affirmed construction so all of those
things are your options right so then
you can for example click on mapping on
genome one genes and then after that we
said that we will do expression level so
we will want to find that was green
right and so expression levels there are
several methods there so the question is
how do we quantify so we'll talk about
that in a second okay so does everybody
see what I see there in the back do it
do I need to repeat this or are you good
yeah can you just yeah okay so just
quickly over here so single or parent
pair ends here organism is grch38 and
you go to upload files and groups and
here you don't do add files you go to
URL bulk upload okay you click on that
you find that svl file choose defined
groups check got all your files listed
right here we don't need roof so we do
cancel no groups and now we are ready to
do this so then I click on start and now
I have these options so the most simple
way to process these fast few files is
just to map everything that we have
on transference so I can just go from
start to volatize to team mapping on
transcripts okay and that would be my
most simple pipeline because now I've
taken those short reads and I mapped
them on whatever is in my GTA 5 and
after I've mapped them so again if I
made a mistake I just right click on
this button and now I go back one step
so I can now read about what does bowtie
do and you will notice that bowtie is
involved here many places and in this
specific case this is tied to T so T
stands for transcripts G will stand for
genome and I can read about the method
right here and if I want the publication
I can really break here safe and after
I've lined those reads to my genome I
need to count ok in this specific
segment how many are stacked up together
so to do that it's actually a
non-trivial procedure called RSM and
what our Sam does is that it analyzes
the overall statistical distribution of
reads and counts in terms of how many
fell together not by chance right so we
don't just count how many we actually
have to use the overall distribution of
reads for the whole transcriptome in
this case and then count accordingly but
here we have a few options so we have
fpkm
expected account and TPM and we'll talk
a little bit about what these mean fpkm
stands for fragment for pure base per
million TP M stands for transcripts per
million and raw count is obviously wrong
count so we're not going to modify the
number in any way now let's keep it at
fpkm click on save you can see that
after our SEM I can actually also
quantify my eggs aunts and not just
transcripts if I lose how interested in
that but for the simplest pipeline we
don't need that okay let's just click on
end click Save
give this a name so you can give it
whatever you want save and then run
pipeline so it's important that not just
save and leave run - if you want to
London right so let's just run it and we
will see is the page will reload and
it's important to notice that right here
will say starter to 1% or something like
that but we will go from prepared to
started you can also go to Mike type
lines and now you can see all of your
pipelines and you can see the latest one
is processing and it's green so that's
an indicator if it's black ok ok ok I'll
just go back to what the pipeline looks
like it's actually just two methods that
we've used so far so it start both types
of teeth and mar 17 2014 5
that will just give you a table of
expression of known transcripts for your
breeds ok did everybody else get to this
point all right so let's talk a little
bit about what are some other options
so we did this so this is going to be
your very basic and the fastest pipeline
and here's what a standard tuxedo
pipeline looks like so it utilizes the
same concepts but in a different way so
you can see that we included some
pre-processing steps right here
traumatic and PCR clean then we went
over here can utilize so from i sat or
top hat which are alternatives of the
same algorithm from here all the way to
over here is going to be your tuxedo
pipeline so highs that maps on genome
identifies exons identifies junctions
and what it produces at the end is the
full alignment file and not alignment
file that is used for combining those
exons into isoforms and then adding them
into a new updated GTF file so instead
of using the reference GTF file it
creates its own GTF file based on those
segments that have found to be exons and
junctions of exons present in your reads
okay then that updated GTF file is used
again in your mapping on the
transcriptome but instead of some
reference transcriptome it's the
transcriptome of this specific sample
and then afterwards of course you need
to still quantify the levels of
expression and so quantification could
be of the actual transcripts and of
exons so if you're interested in two
differences between end zone expression
that gives you a little bit more of a
detailed view so this is an expanded
pipeline disk
what other pipeline doing hang on well
if we start from both i2g right here
which is just the mapping on genome
we have an option to also visualize our
alignment so if we actually want to go
back and scroll through the whole genome
and see where the reads are we can use
bow type to G and then connected to
visualization but that is essentially
the first step that provides us with a
lot of opportunities actually map on the
genome and so you can see that we can
also use a novel eggs on detection just
based on segmentation a different option
and then from there you can creatively
analyze the data yourself for example in
the following way so you can identify
new exons create a new adjustment to the
GTF then map on junctions using bowtie i
and they created construction of
isoforms music ISO lasso merge the GTF
adjusted with the known GTF and then go
from there on the same path to actually
align them and want to find them using
our simple a fool just a visualization
pipeline if you want to visualize all of
your reeds will look like this so quote
IgG visualization and so this is just to
give you an idea of what you can do and
the different strategies of mapping that
you can use any questions ok so then
let's take a look at what would be the
results so here we ran our simple
pipeline well actually before we deal
with the simple pipeline why don't we
create a full pipeline using the
pre-processing steps and we'll just have
it so you have it saved so if we go back
to the platform again I will start front
you can just click here under create our
AC pipeline because you're already in
this section you can also use this drop
down menu and go to NGS RNA SEC gene
chip or you can go to areas of analysis
and go right here and each area of
analysis will
have this little informational tool tip
if you want to know what that section
does so if I go back and I create a new
pipeline again I will have the same
settings so there and fast q grch38
upload files and groups URL bulk upload
samples that appeal define groups check
cancel no groups and now I can build my
pipeline start I will select from
pre-processing I will use traumatic
because that trims the adapters then I
will clean up the replicates that
represents a technical variation because
they will be highly conserved they will
be exactly the same stack together and
then from here I can utilize for example
high set to from high satu you can see
that I only have a few options so I will
use cufflinks cuff merge and then go
type to the teeth and our same
expression table and again here I can
choose fpkm or I might be interested in
transcript para million and it will talk
a little bit about the difference
between those and here I can just do
expanded or deceived ok so if you want
to play around with this you can run
several of these pipelines and then take
a look at the different results now this
will take some time
alright so don't expect this to be done
in five minutes these are actual fast
queue files and we have an eleven of
them each one is approximately given by
size so probably in a couple of days you
will see the results so you will get an
email notification this is done it will
click through and you will be able to
see the results now if you want to see
the results of pipeline with results
I will to you here in a second okay so
this is the pipeline so notice just so
how do you find other you know for
educational accounts these are shared
pipelines all right so this is only
going to work with the pipelines that
you create in this course and it's only
going to work for the pipeline step on
with files that are uploaded to the
server but basically you have a number
for each pipeline so right here you see
at the end three eight eight six six
seven three so all of you can find this
pipeline right so if I take this link
I'll put it here on chat for those
people that are online if you want to
take a look at it you can go into your
pipeline and just change the number at
the end and do three eight eight six six
73 at the end of that link though three
eight eight six six 73 and you should
see my pipeline because here you will
already have the output files you also
have the output files in the zip archive
that I gave you the same but this is
what you will see if you open download
files you will see several things
expression of genes fpkm filtered and
not filtered expression of isoforms and
then you will also see mapping
statistics so these would be mapping
statistics how many leads were mapped in
each sample and you can see a variation
there and of course that will affect
what we are trying to measure and the
main thing that we want to look at is
the table of expression so for example
this would be the gene expression table
and this is what it looks like so if we
download this file so expression genes
fpkm I just click on it it will download
and then what I can do is for example
open it in Excel so I just drag it on to
itself it's a tab delimited file so that
means that the columns are separated by
tab and what you will see is that let me
make this bigger okay this is what you
see inside the table
okay so yeah so catching up puts on the
live stream of questions I didn't know
which GTF file to use since there are so
many NCBI and other places so each
assembly for example we're using the
human genome so he just simply will come
with its updated GTF file but typically
any organism assembly if it has a GPS
that GTF will be will have a version so
just like we had grch37 and 38 years
those are versions and so we decided to
use 38 first and what you see on the
platform are the most up-to-date
versions that we have found but you can
also upload your own GTF so you can
download the GTF and then if you will
have a faster file for the sequence the
GTF file for the positions and that
sequence and then you can upload both of
those i'm use them as reference the
other question or if you make your own
GTF file like that once you lose the
annotations that are associated with the
already made ones so we don't make a
completely new one we adjust the old one
with new things that we find so that's
why it's an adjustment
that is then merged together and so
you're actually using information from
the known and your own okay so what are
we seeing here in this table as you
remember in that visual representation
of the gene signature panel and 50 the
columns are going to be your samples the
rows are going to be genes so this is an
ensemble ID of a specific gene and it's
gene and what's inside is the level of
expression so if we go over here now we
can talk about what do these numbers
actually mean and what are these
measurements of fpkm
TPM or Rockhouse so this would be the
sample name this would be the gene ID
and of course that would be the
expression look but in what numbers what
are we using you so here are some idea
of what these measurements actually
represent so FPGAs down stands for
fragments per kilobytes per million of
mapped reads so it actually accounts for
two things one is the total number of
reads for that particular sample and the
second thing is the length of gene
so if imagine you have a gene that is
you know 2,000 kilobases long and 500
kilobases long the statistically
speaking more reads are going to fall
onto the longer genes just because it's
longer right so that is one way to
overcome that difference between genes
the second consideration is let's say I
have a bucket that is a hundred percent
full and a bucket that is 50 percent for
so I just have different amounts that
I'm comparing so just because this one
is 100 percent flow and 50 percent flow
I'm already going to expect that in the
differential gene expression a lot of
genes from this bucket are just going to
have higher expression even though
that's not
really representative of the biology
because the biology should be related to
what's overall happening in that
specific sample so that's why we want to
adjust and normalize the total number of
reads using as our baseline measure so
we align them and then we measure
everything related to that measure of
the total of map reads now some people
would argue that the length of the gene
does not matter and that's why it's
becoming more popular maybe today or
some would say TPM as the standard and
so TPM does not account for the length
of the Jeep
it just accounts for the total number of
mapped reads okay but essentially other
than that it's the same concept it's a
way to normalize your numbers so that
they are more comparable between
different changes just to show you what
is how does that relate to our dataset
that information is going to be here
under mapping stats table so if I
download that file again I can open it
in Excel and it gives me a lot of some
what's useful data but not exactly maybe
but what you can see here is that the
first line okay it is going to be for
this sample okay so I can look at it if
use it utilizes the alignment mapping so
the Sam file is their alignment nothing
and then this for example would be my
second set so now I want to check
whether between these two there is a
difference in how much how many reads
were mapped so you can see that this was
74% this was 76% 8163 etc so the overall
alignment variance
so if you can now clean up this table
and just leave the sample names you can
actually see okay so but let's say I'll
take the first four not to take up too
much of our time and I can create a
little bar plot of the alignment between
these different and it goes
is it possible to access the raw leaks
yeah you can just open the last coupon
that's what you mean right
the fast few files are available you can
of course so this would be you can see
that for example there is a difference
between these two and so if I'm just
comparing the gene expression between
those two samples I am already going to
be expecting some difference that is not
related to the difference in the genes
that are being expressed okay so does
anybody have any questions about this so
here I'm there were several tools listed
to do the same job for example to method
genome you have star power pay and PWA
and to Matt the transcription of PW 80
of these so how do we know which program
to choose to map the genome to do the
same job yes so the idea is that you can
compare there are many papers that do
you know comparisons between how well
they perform and they seem to be
performing for different tasks a little
bit differently so a lot of people for
example utilize star when they're
interested in gene fusion you know bwa
and bowtie are different algorithms that
do the same thing and it's been kind of
shown that bowtie is more accurate so
but still there are widely used for all
the same kinds of studies and so the
idea of placing them
the same category would be to give you
the option to try different things and
come up with your own conclusion of what
you want for a specific you know they
all have the output so I'm going to be a
little bit different the methods that
they use are a little bit different and
you can search literature for how they
compare in terms of benchmarking for
speed benchmarking for axes right those
would be the considerations that you
would have so the idea is that the
sequencers have a certain rate of error
and so when you do the same thing from
different ends it's like you do it twice
and so you have a higher confidence in
the actual sequence of that read that is
the major benefit and then the analysis
changes a little bit in terms of how
exactly you combine because they're not
the same read from the same side from
two different sides but it gives you
also a better sense of that segment
beginning at so yeah there isn't it's
just related to what's your source data
if your data was prepared as parent you
can use parent but it's always a
prepared a single ending can't use based
on what day that you have any other
questions
okay so next we want to talk about
differential gene expression so now we
have a sense of what is in the
expression table how do we compare
between two groups of samples so the
idea would be exactly the same process
we first do pre-processing with a new
mapping and then do quantification and
then afterwards we do differential gene
expression right because at the end we
are comparing numbers so we have to give
to the point of having numbers and then
we can compare those numbers and this is
where it's going to be useful having TP
m and F began because that is a way to
normalize those numbers and prepare them
for this kind of analysis now what is
differential gene expression what are we
actually trying to do right so we want
to compare conditions okay so in the
context of our day is that what are the
conditions that we have so breast cancer
is a condition of all of them different
types of exactly so we have we're
comparing two different subtypes of
breast cancer and so what where do we
know which ones what from this case
like so which one is 687 oh right ok so
we need to look up the sample right so
let's map our samples in the same
downloaded file under input files and
expression quantification you have this
file called cell lines clinical type
that tells us actually what these sample
code names stand for right so if we if
you look at this ID you can now know
which subject so what we can do is we
can just for example color this yellow
green ok so we want to compare and
differential gene expression how normal
like is different from Wow so 720 or
let's start from the beginning 6 8 7 6 8
8 are normal like six nine seven is
clouded lower so we can do these as
green and then we have 697 703 714 so
all of these are and then we have 716
720 is green and then 720 is
non-malignant 721 is non-malignant it
was make these yellow
7:26 is about it love 34 is not so what
we're really doing here is we are
creating those groups right so because
in the end we want to know which file to
drag where so we have to have some kind
of a reference and 36 is also cloud lilo
so ideally what I would want to do for
my differential gene expression is
organize them so that they are next to
each other all right so I can move this
around okay so the idea of differential
gene expression would be to see for this
specific gene right if I select it like
this could I see a difference right so
now i reorganize them and I can see so
it goes up to 34 so these would be
normal like and these would be cloud in
blood so just looking at this table any
idea which one has a higher expression
clouded low or normal life just by
looking at these numbers yellow ones
aren't the normal right yellow ones are
normal egg and the green ones so up
until here right so these would be all
of these are normal like all of these
are clouded look what do you think which
group is higher expressed than the other
number one so these are all anemones
these are what overexposed by how much
if we take the average we will say that
like we need cuz in some cases is
whoa it will like six surfaces is really
low right but there's a video hi like
714 maybe yeah average you thing is a
good way to measure that overall for
overall look
okay so I need to take an average right
and then I'm saying that you know
somewhere so let's do that real quick
just so we get a sense of what's in here
all right so now I can prepare an
average so this will be average for
normal length and this will be average
or clouded low so this would be yellow
and I can just do average right here and
select all the beats and then I can do
the same for this one and select all of
these the comes a lot of the versions
right columns or blue columns are their
individual samples right that's samples
are coming from different cell lines so
these are different songs okay so now I
have on average 7.5 and on average 10.33
is there a difference it finds your
senior pills okay so how do I measure
the difference what would be the
difference between one group
Leathernecks t-tests all right good
we're getting somewhere so okay so now
we have the idea of checking what is t
does to actually do right so we're
really now doing hypothesis testing
right we're starting with we assume that
there's no difference and if there is a
significant p-value right probability
that this could not
happened by chance we say that there is
actually a difference right so that
would be one measurement so let's do
that normal distribution well right now
no but first of all we will we can talk
about yeah doing some descriptive
statistics on our data that would be a
useful step but right now we just want
to understand differential gene
expression so this will be more similar
to disk for this versus this but I get a
p-value what's a good here 0.5 0.5 word
0.05 all right so is there a difference
no okay so that is one parameter that we
use and what is another parameters let's
say there was a difference let's say it
was your point zero four what else how
do I then quantify this difference so we
use something called full change right
so full change would be what is the
number that I can assign to this
difference so those are the two things
that you need to kind of remember for
differential gene expression is that
we're going to be using p-values and
full change to measure the difference
and it's also important to remember
difference between in one and what right
so your order your sequence of what you
put in one group and the second group is
going to be important because that will
be your full change it's one between the
other so what would be the voltage yeah
for example would be this is the first
group right
divided by this group so 0.72 you can
also do Mike
you can just subtract one from the other
you can also do a logarithmic for
so so remember that that number is going
to be representative of what you decided
so now the problem is so let's say I can
do all of this in Excel so why do I need
to do differential gene expression well
one of the problems is that I just have
a lot of genes let's take a look at how
many do I have I have close to 20,000
genes right so I can go one two and
maybe select number 500 but at the end
they have a lot of genes that I have to
deal with and then I have to select
those genes that are actually have a
good p-value and have a high enough fold
change that I can actually say that they
are differentially expressed and I can
try and interpret that difference so
let's go back I was told that we need to
wrap up so let's quickly create a
differential gene expression I blank so
let's again select here parent and here
the reference genome and let us upload
the files and now we need to create our
group so let's create two groups and now
we need a reference table okay and I
want to drag them in appropriate group
so I will do my first group will be
non-malignant so I will take the 720 and
then we'll have 727 21 and 6 34 so all
of these are normal length the
disturbing for 687 and 680 all of these
are going to be
normally and all of these are going to
be out in love and I can do continue and
this is for contrasts between
segmentation if I was to use
segmentation and identify new segments I
will use contrast but here we actually
just select all will just do that let's
do start and now we do let's do the most
simple one again so let's skip the
pre-processing let's just go to bowtie
to T our some expression table and you
can and now I have this option to do
differential gene expression so I can
choose between n jar d ii v SEC - if I
wasn't using the cuff merge cufflinks
etc I would be able to use v so let's go
make a movie set to and you can read
about it right here and end
what would be the output of these
different files and by the way you can
use their jar and then you can compare
what's the difference so we're not going
to wait for this to finish but you do
have in your output files right here and
their output files you have differential
expression and here you have the output
from be set to and from a chart so let's
take a look at be set to okay so here's
what we have here we have log 2 of fold
change this is the standard error for
log for change and then we have p value
and P adjusted by the same thing would
be there for edge our planet an over
different terminology so they have log
to full change log of change and then p
value plus FDR is actually the t
adjusted value so you have all the same
information here right so now that we
have this table how do we actually
select those genes that are
differentially expressed from this table
for example we can use the P adjusted
value first and we can filter for
everything that is less than okay so the
problem here is that you have these n a
s right and so it's going to have a
problem with those two
you overcome this we can be the
following we can actually filter out all
the ones that have I don't have they
make any of us just talking all of this
okay so now we can make this a little
bigger okay so less than or equal to
what's a good p-value new point zero
five okay let's see how many I have that
are different that how is statistical
significance that would be my first
things to look at so I have a total of
twenty two thousand two hundred fifty
things like that and the second thing
that I want to use is log full change so
I want to again filter out the ones that
are that most different right so
thirteen would be the cold change
between those two groups and let's say I
will go to a minimum of one point five
and I'm not really interested anything
below that so let's say one point five
will give me about nine hundred and
thirty more jeans that have a difference
right so let's just check what does that
look like
so I'll just mark that with color here
in the second method is kind of beat
wise matching like like in the Rope
sequence in the second differentiating
differentiating well you first do all
the same stuff and create a table of
expression and then we do what which is
giving itself or if we compare the means
see whether the city the second dress is
we are using that's well not exactly
that you have the same principles okay
so let's just check what this gene so
let's take the first one the most
differentiated and go back to our
expression
dangle and see what's inside so here I
will find that gene though it's right
here and I can create my bar plot and
here you can already see that the
difference is quite obvious right so now
I've selected a gene that totally has
transcription here but has zero or close
to zero if we select a gene that does
not have a good p-value so we actually
take something in research for that it
was this one right so now I see the
difference the difference in these
differential differentially expressed
genes would be that on average within
this group there is a significance and
there's a quantifiable difference so
this was we'll wrap up for today and
that was it for gene expression and
differential gene expression you will
find in the online modules some more
examples of things that you can do
including normalization and exploration
of your data and in the next workshop we
will work through the rest of the
methods and kind of go all the way to
the end to interpretation to pathway
annotation to gene ontology etc any
questions it accounts for false
discovery actually any other questions
[Music]
how do ya know because that is just one
way to normalize his look at the total
number of weeks where you would want to
do really is to do summary statistics
and do her you look at your moments look
at your skewness your distribution etc
and then through normalization based on
those for example of utilities you have
something that's called quantile
normalization right so yeah there is a
exactly you do the means you line the
means and you you actually normalize
adjust for its own right so there's a
certain level of noise